victory day is the most important annual
event for russians
but this year it has added significance
because of the conflict in ukraine
11 000 troops paraded through red square
in moscow to commemorate the soviet
victory over nazi germany 77 years ago
an estimated 27 million soldiers and
civilians from the soviet union died in
what the russians call the great
patriotic war
president vladimir putin used the
occasion to compare the fight against
hitler to his so-called special military
operation in ukraine
you're fighting for our people in
donbass for the safety of our motherland
russia may the 9th 1945 will always be a
triumph of our single soviet people
russia's preemptively rebuffed the
aggression it was timely and the only
right decision the decision of a strong
sovereign independent country
as the missiles and other military
hardware paraded through the streets
onlookers backed their president's
decision to send russian troops into
ukraine
i think the operation had to take place
we must win it bring it to its logical
end only this way not a single step back
i fully support the decision of the
russian government i don't condemn it i
think we would have ended up with nazism
this is evil
we must erase all this in ukraine this
fascist tribe must be wiped out from the
world completely that's why putin is
doing everything right always
putin didn't say when the operation
might end but he also didn't use his
speech to broaden the conflict or make a
formal declaration of war as some had
feared
this war appeared to be much more
difficult and bloody as then uh we
expected we expected that uh this will
be uh battle for uh dunbas will continue
uh probably to the until the
middle of uh summer and then
based on the result of this battle on
the bus
new political decisions
will be made putin laid flowers at
memorials to the 12 so-called hero
cities which include odessa and kiev for
outstanding heroism during world war ii
the commemorations continued as
president putin led the procession of
what russians call the immortal regiment
carrying a portrait of his father who
fought in world war ii defending the
city of saint petersburg he was joined
by thousands of others who lost
relatives in the war
similar ceremonies were held across
russia and in occupied territories of
ukraine
in what is left of mariopol
russian-backed separatist leader dennis
pushalin told a small crowd that russia
is here forever
president putin says he has no doubt
that the military operation will achieve
its objectives in ukraine
while he continues to use his country's
past to justify its present a tactic
that's proven to be mostly successful so
far within russia
dorset chaparri al jazeera moscow